El Vaticano confirmó en un comunicado de
prensa el deterioro de la salud del Papa
emérito Benedicto 16 debido a su edad
avanzada Benedicto tiene 95 años El
Vaticano también señala que este
miércoles el Papa Francisco ha visitado
a Benedicto un pontífice que marcó la
historia fue el primer papa que renunció
a su cargo en casi 600 años lo anunció
el 11 de febrero de 2013 después de ocho
años de pontificado se le considera un
tradicionalista conservador que tomó las
riendas de la Iglesia Católica en el año
2005 desde su renuncia vive recluido en
un antiguo convento situado dentro de
los jardines vaticanos en donde se ha
dedicado en estos últimos años
principalmente a la oración y al estudio
de textos de teología acompañado por su
secretario personal monseñor George
gainsbain quien ha confirmado como en
los últimos años el papa emérito ha ido
perdiendo progresivamente sus fuerzas
pero no sus habilidades mentales
claramente en estos momentos el mundo
católico sigue con ansiedad la evolución
del estado de salud de Benedicto 16 el
papa número
265 de la iglesia católica